what up what up what up what up what up
it connect
it is march 24th thursday
we're here a day early because
we are going to vegas tomorrow
for abey's birthday
that's why i'm just really being careful
with my throat we canceled our show
yesterday
yeah i mean it wasn't even an option man
i couldn't talk
on my day we did a three hour long
episode and my throat was just so torn
up
i started taking antibiotics the next
morning
is it better
it's helped i think it's helped
i mean
i don't i don't know i feel like if i
didn't start taking it i probably would
have gotten some serious like
throat damage this is so i think so
but i'm gonna try to keep it short today
two hours max dan cut me off
okay
i i have a new cut off button
just give us even more thorough just
give us some heads up as we approach the
two hour mark okay no heads up no heads
up just just just kill it all right
oh today's episode is sponsored by
master class and hello fresh sure is
and having throat damage
not a good
injury to have when your job is to talk
for a living
[Music]
it's the money maker right there
yeah
ultimate
anyway we're back we're here we got a
heck of a show here for you guys today
um ela how are you how's your week been
good
good good good good good
wow you said good a lot because um bruce
has been so cute and theodore too
he's just uh
living in cute world
nice
and your husband my husband is very cute
oh
so nice of you to say that unprovoked i
want you to be better already it sucks
dude i've been saying for so long yeah
it's just like you know
for like a month
i'm so over it dude it's just annoying
and now it's like
for me it's not even fun sick you know
sometimes there's fun sick where you're
just like oh i'm sick i gotta stay and
play video games all day oh you're a
parent so you're a dad
yeah so it's like over it
well doesn't work like that anymore well
there's that one and there's like oh
everybody take care of me but then
there's like oh i'm actually suffering i
can't do my job
my biggest fear in life is to be sick i
hate just being sick
it gives me
horrible anxiety
really just like a cold any sickness any
sickness yeah
worse than ccr
[Music]
yeah
it's bad though
[Music]
hey beef
yes sir what do you want to do this
weekend is there anything particular you
want to do um
just hang out with you guys
i know i'm just super excited i heard
zach that you got the suit i'm very
excited about that i got a suit yeah
that got me hyped up yeah okay today
when i'm packing i got some fly ass
loafers too and
everyone got swag that everyone's got a
dress tonight i mean you do have just
whatever you want not nice just wear
whatever you want yeah whatever you want
you just feel good baby chantal got some
nice dresses too and um yeah we're gonna
we're gonna look fly as [ __ ] it's
exciting
to simp a little the first time me and
lena went to vegas
it was around the time you guys won your
first lawsuit
and i shot the intro to my video
defending you in vegas so it's really
thrilled to be going back with you guys
like
yeah that's great we won our first
lawsuit 2018.
and then you shot the intro defending us
that timeline doesn't make any sense
that's a [ __ ] simp
i don't know it lined up though i mean i
i think it was another video that i was
going to use that intro for but i ended
up using it for
you know
wow and now you're back in vegas and
uh
well there's no lawsuits to win but uh
you get to be with me yeah
[Applause]
oh my boy my boy gabe how are you
are you driving
i'm in a car right now with somebody i'm
i'm very disappointed and i'm confused
it's on thursday instead of friday make
me think it's friday already
yeah you know what we're doing the show
a day early
we should have yeah i'm so sorry to
confuse you like that because tomorrow
there's not going to be a call huh
oh okay
now i understand that yes but i'm still
confused
today's friday [ __ ] me [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] baby pissing my ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] thursday pissing my ass thursday
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] thursday's a beast tomorrow [ __ ]
you say [ __ ] so good
say [ __ ]
tomorrow's friday baby
yeah tomorrow's friday but today's
thursday how do you feel about thursday
as a day
thursday is it's it's good i'd say i'd
say
the new friday i would say oh
friday
all right but where are you headed
uh we're heading to um some meaning to
some discussions and stuff [ __ ] oh
maybe
yeah business movie big moves baby
baby wow
big moves [ __ ]
yes
who's driving
uh a friend of mine
let's see him
oh he's not here right i was getting
something there's there's nobody there
yet nobody that
are you in a parking lot or in your own
driveway
we're in a parking lot we're getting
some soup and stuff like for lunch [ __ ]
it's soup thursdays soup thursdays
all right gabe well you have a great
thursday you crushed it at that meeting
okay
sure yeah good luck
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] maybe [ __ ] next week
buddy see you next week you have a great
weekend all right
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah dude you're the best all right you
take care of woo
[ __ ]
[ __ ] baby
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh
[Laughter]
don't hurt your throat now
see you later gabe [ __ ] my ass [ __ ]
yeah i'm all hungover from taking nyquil
too
so i'm not
totally present
that was fun though
you're not the only one i've been having
really bad allergies this week
really bad um and so i went to the store
and got that that claritin stuff like
the good one that they keep behind the
counter or whatever it's been years
since i've taken this
i [ __ ] zooed it dude
is it like speedy or sleepy speedy
really
it's the stuff that
you can make speed out of oh
it's like i learned that in breaking bad
the only uh antihistamine i've taken
makes me sleepy this does not make you
sleepy
sleepy and horny i need to get zooded my
dude
all right well that was good times um
got a lot to get to obviously
um
dude this guy's off the rails bro
zach aren't you kind of getting close to
getting in touch with wally i have uh
it's kind of a long story but which i
don't know if i should stay on the air
but
i'm it's close we could make it happen
but yes so everything is in motion some
things we've been trying
to get wally to call in for i don't know
a year plus with the help of ab too i
don't know i can't take all that is live
for 50 minutes trying to
i don't think he reads to be honest um
yeah
but you guys got in touch with someone
very close to him family member yeah
yeah
and i only was in that live for like
five minutes
so here's wally a guest in his apartment
building
and he is there's a fire engine an
ambulance somebody died i think and
wally thinks this is very funny
usa
tomorrow today
somebody go to hell
he said somebody go to hell
well that's his catchphrase right
he says a lot of people somebody go to
hell go buy them
yeah exactly
oh what what
sick then
they go to
emergency
pass away i'll go to hell
oh my god
he sounds like he ate their soul
yeah he goes i know they went to hell
because i sent them there
um
9-1-1
supposedly
they couldn't find the pokemon through
we were just work on the party
department they want to
make a same charge money
and this is not like that's about it
right yeah yeah yeah you got the job the
laughter was truly i mean i don't think
we ever heard it
yeah
yeah no it's an amazing that that breath
at the end
he takes in we were looping that
yesterday we thought of time like vader
it's tick tocks just keep getting banned
and he'll just make a new account oh wow
he has like a whole discord of followers
who try to find his whereabouts and yeah
why does he keep getting banned because
he's wishing
yeah
yeah yeah he gets a little wild on i
love his persistence though yeah he
grinds
[Laughter]
hey
it ain't easy being a legend
he reminds me of a character from like
um
spawn you remember that spawn
you think of the big clown guy yeah yeah
yeah yeah pull that up if you can find
it yeah there's the evil clown from
spawn that looks just like wally
good [ __ ] violator
violator
there is
this guy right yeah
you know the tesla crash that you guys
were talking about that that sound that
it makes the the crash was like a
perfect like accident soundtrack oh
that's true
well that was you feel it with like a
few bottles
falling at the end like a few
i've got it up next we can listen for
the oh you do it there's an update yeah
yeah yeah really funny one
feet up court two hands two hands go go
go girl
[Music]
don't let go
yeah so
we saw the
same exact accident happened to someone
else yeah
i don't know if it's the same zip line
people but they all got to get their
oh
they got to figure out the physics on
this thing two hands two hands go go go
girl
don't let go
how does that happen dude they just did
the same exact thing happened to a
different person they're just these
aren't professional zipliners
it like stops her
something stops her immediately and her
body is just not ready there's too much
momentum don't let go
oh chat wants to fit check either
yeah i know i don't know we'll show it
off then girl come on
oh with this shot well let's take a look
at you podcast
oh that's a fancy brand
the shirt is teddy fresh yeah
you want to show off some of the
hardware
oh the hardware yeah i got some sick
like stuff here but
uh i don't know
i don't know how to do this
all right
and the shoes do you want to throw the
shoes on the table shoes i got
converse plastic classic good for every
outfit right that's what they say
yeah
i want to smell feet
i'm wearing teddy fresh head to toe
baby
represent
representation represent representative
um
what's this yeah so you know
uh
another
spider-man uh
another spider-man moment
[Music]
[Laughter]
did he like break his wrist what
happened oh you lost his what happened
the web
i wonder if they paid that guy
[Laughter]
[Music]
i wonder
that's it oh [ __ ]
that's awesome
spider-man's not an easy gig man i'll
tell you get your [ __ ] ass up and
work
right spider-man work harder
by the way i've been thinking about that
obviously there was we had a huge debate
on the show about the kardashians
and for some reason i don't think anyone
expected
that uh the audience would come down
hard
yeah on me and ela for saying the
kardashians didn't fake
that the controversy i don't i don't
know how it looks for them but it's so
awkward like we're just friends talking
whenever we see those comments those are
the only things that make me
uncomfortable personally like i it's
it's you
i don't know what the hell they were
watching i can't believe all the
comments like there was even like a a t
video about it
otherwise
it is [ __ ] crazy what uh
yeah i don't know i mean
but regardless um
i've been thinking about that a lot i
still think that that situation was fake
or i mean real
i honestly i hate to say it i'm at a
loss for words because i don't want to
go there again because i'm like
you know what i realized i don't know
what to say without people thinking that
i'm like
do you know what the real crazy or
something i realized
the real pr
was them convincing the world that every
dumb thing they do was on
purpose right there
yeah as evil said i'm i'm afraid to even
comment i'm not even going there i'm
telling you
thanks guys
i don't care you can't you can't be
prisoner to these [ __ ] wackos i know
but every once in a while but
it's hard to ignore this yeah
people were really angry yeah and they
didn't start throwing out words like
abusive like
guys
going on here i just witnessed a real
abuse of power yeah
and it's just awkward to even talk about
it i don't know what to say that's why
i'm like i don't even want to say
anything
whatever
this is what i have to say suck my dick
yeah no it feels shitty after a long you
know
work week and seeing people attacking
people you care about for no reason it's
just a bummer we're just friends talking
don't look too much into it it is a
bummer i agree but you know it's like at
the end of the day
you know like like if you look at the
like ratio that's what it was about to
say these were good i was like wow
there's a lot of negative feedback i
wonder how the episode's doing it's like
views are good the like ratio is the
same as it always is like i don't know i
think like that we've obviously garnered
some a lot of new audience from the
frenemies era
and some percentage of those people
which by the way i'm glad they're here
and i'm glad they're watching i'm not
saying don't watch which i like that
you're here and it's fine but there's a
there's a certain percent of people that
are very sensitive
to um
their empaths what can i say no no
they're true i don't put that on them
[Laughter]
and so
and not everybody uh has that dynamic i
mean we're
we're a group of people that you know
we're all we're all friendly and and we
all like each other and when we disagree
on something we we argue about it
passionately but it's not it's not
abusive it's not i am also israeli and
when israelis talk with passion it can
come off as aggressive sometimes or like
if like ethan will sometimes ask me are
these people fighting and it's like no
they're just talking yeah it's not an
argument
personally that's my favorite part of
the show is when we go back and forth
yeah me too
i think it's awesome that we can
disagree and talk about it but
i don't know well there was two peop
there was two camps there was one camp
that was angry that me and you were mean
to love and av
and then there was another camp that was
like i can't believe how [ __ ] dumb
they are yeah and how out of the
actually steve
or they were like how dare you compare
yourself to the kardashians no
we're not first of all
something i don't know man this is just
crazy sometimes the reactions people
have but it's okay yeah it's fine i like
i said don't keep watching
i don't give a [ __ ] bruh it's sick being
freaking deep bro it's weird too because
sometimes sometimes you wrap up a show
and you're like
that one
that one didn't necessarily hit you know
yeah it happens not not that we don't
have a good time every time but
sometimes like you know
that one last week
didn't have a thought like that at all
it was like great show everybody yeah
that was fun
yeah that was a very mild disagreement
in my opinion yeah but yeah i guess
people
have different well nobody i don't give
a [ __ ] about the kardashians you know
what i mean right
but anyway i still i stand by my i
haven't changed my stance i do think
that was real
yeah but don't you think that's a easier
and more makes more sense from a pr
where you go listen every time you all
say or do something dumb
tell everyone it's on purpose that is
the calculation
that's all comes razor right that makes
the most sense
you can't
i don't
we're talking about when kim kardashian
went she did an interview and she's like
people just don't want to work
and then one of the other bozos was like
that's so true so true
nobody wants to work these days
and so what love said that he thinks
that was faked potentially
also and there's
another layer to it where
everyone working on that show
wants them to look bad
producers and stuff like that they try
to do that stuff i mean that makes sense
they do core controversy for attention
and everything like any reality show
they love the
they always edit it to make them look as
bad
as possible that's why we love it by the
way i'm just squirting what is this
chloroseptic
wait you're spraying that in your mouth
yeah that's not oral the bum i'm just
kidding i'm just kidding i was like i
sure taste like a ghost
um interesting nice little tingling does
it work
helping the throat
this could help me deep throat
hey
i've seen you with that burrito i
remember
oh no
oh no stop
don't make me hit the let's work that
button
who's getting hard
joe that's inappropriate
joe rogan
so anyway funny little thing though it's
fine
i've really gotten used to all the
people like people getting angry at me
to an extent
it does it does hurt though especially
when you know your intentions are good
and people aren't taking it right
but
in a way it hurts in a way that's
tolerable and fine
and not a big deal
sometimes in fleeting moments i'm i'm
like [ __ ] them i'm never doing the show
again
when i get really like i go how [ __ ] oh
i'm i'm [ __ ] retiring [ __ ] this
the good thing for me is that i also
listen to the show so i have the
listener point of view from my own
experience and i know that when i listen
i enjoy pretty much everything
and sometimes people will think
something was messed up and i was like i
thought it was totally fine so i have
that like perspective so i can still
use that perspective when i'm involved
in the situation sure
but it's hard
to
i don't know it messes with your
perspective for sure yeah yeah
well there it is
i and if you guys ever criticized me
again i'm [ __ ] retiring you
understand [ __ ]
love that's not nice don't call our fans
[ __ ]
stop
it's just not appropriate
i would never never bro i could deep
throat a fat one right now this [ __ ] is
like numb to my throat entirely don't
don't test that theory okay you want to
bring this to vegas
you want this keemstar [ __ ]
no
all right where were we we're talking
about something
we were talking about our kelly cameos
from prison
this is so wild
it says when your dad goes to the same
prison as r kelly
i wanted to ask you something can you
sing a song for me
which one love letter
did you get my call oh my god i thought
she was gonna say passport
[Music]
[Music]
that's crazy
dude he's just like damn i'll take any
fan i can get wow
that's such a good comment i would not
be letting r kelly sing to my daughter
even from prison yeah
i love the wording when your dad goes to
the same person like it's a school yeah
he attends the same prison you know
ask you something can you sing a song
for me
can you do that at prison just be like
yo here's my homie i thought it was all
more
strict than that apparently not i'm not
sure but i will say i read a few
articles and no one was able to
officially confirm
that this is legit but it looks like it
is for the most part i believe it for
some reason could be a really good
singer that can just sound like him
it's got to be him they're like joking
it's got to be him
um
i mean prisoners are making tick tocks
so why can't they call make calls
yeah well they call i mean calls are
like a sanction thing even like you you
can pay
it costs a bunch of money but you can
make calls from prison oh i know but
like
maybe they're both in the in the room i
don't know
with me wants to say what's up
well i'm saying that they can just pass
it to anyone that is a crazy concept
like you have a cell block with white or
something yeah that's a good point
so but listen to this though which one
love letter
did you what is that sound
she goes he goes what song you want me
to sing love letter he goes
oh like does he know that song yeah
maybe he gets that a lot or something
he's in prison though what are you
complaining how many requests you get
you get my call
that's got to be him
that's your boy r kelly
my god
so crazy
shout outs man
i would let r kelly out of prison if he
would just do interviews all day
like he can't have any freedom
we'll monitor him we'll put an ankle
bracelet on him and then like make sure
he's not like putting any women into his
basement or whatever but just have him
doing interviews all day just for
the content yeah yeah
you're killing me man
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh if we had normal day jobs i haven't
seen this
this is good huh
i have some
67 points which one of you crew members
wrote this
[Laughter]
not
not me i i so i took issue with some of
these that's kind of why i wanted to
ethan ethan would be a telemarketer
phone customer service
insurance rep
who was good at reading in between the
lines or a zookeeper what the [ __ ]
why are we all getting like [ __ ]
jobs like well that i mean
first of all let's not be disrespectful
to the jobs these are these are all okay
jobs
but
yeah um i don't i don't get the
zookeeper for you i just i don't get any
of this for you too well why'd you put
it in the dock then it's got 60 points
because i thought we could discuss what
what we really i think you'd be a chef
for no reason
patients start everything
and i think you would be a uh
janitor
and a b would be a [ __ ] uh janitor's
assistant
oh you wouldn't even be a janitor wow
i'd be like good will hunting janitor
though
no well i'm actually a genius and i
solve equations at harvard
no way bro you be the janitor at like
the [ __ ] uh itt tech
[Laughter]
it's not your fault
it is your fault
zack as a bowling alley pin monkey
and [ __ ] is that
you're the guy who resets up the pins
when they get knocked over i think
you know
they have a scene to do that nowadays
but maybe it's an old bowling alley or
something all right well let's talk
if we're going to keep it to
two hours
let's see we've got
the tesla jump update let's talk about
that uh we're actually at 30. so if you
want to uh move on to a bigger story
let's uh hit those as real quick
[ __ ] all right i'm gonna blast through
these
whoops blast them
won't blast these [ __ ] ass guys
and thank you to the one and only
hello
fresh
feeding fupa troopers around
the world
changing the game
making burritos what's inside
it could be pork it could be chicken it
could be beef
it could be anything but i'll tell you
what i know is inside of that burrito
something good that's true that's right
that is so true
vegetarian that is so true unforgettable
experience
that's abs burrito of course
but there's not but that's not all we've
made oh that looks that is unbelievable
some real food wow there's some real oh
that's true that's true
we send these in via discord thank you
to you guys
hmm
here's how it works hellofresh delivers
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door
skip the trips to the grocery store and
count on hello fresh to make
cooking at home easy fun and affordable
and that's why it's america's number one
meal kit
um you can customize your favorite
dishes with their hello custom offerings
by swapping out one protein or side for
another or you can upgrade for a more
luxe experience or even adding protein
to a veggie meal that means more choice
more variety and more meals truly
tailored to you plus quick and easy
meals
uh
include a 20 minute meal
which has low prep easy cleanup
and even provides a faster route to
putting food on the table
so yeah you can cut back your time in
the kitchen
um the thing is it's honestly it
couldn't even save you money from eating
out or even going to the grocery store
because there's no wastage it sends you
just what you want it's in a card with
all the instructions telling exactly
what to do you're going to learn you're
going to grow you're going to be making
bomb food
at home
yes you who would have thought and not
only that
uh you can go to hellofresh.com after
dark 16 and use the code after dark 16
to get up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts do i know what the three
gifts are no
it's a surprise
do we
i i i don't know either i don't know
but i'm sure they're great
yeah
go to hellofresh.com after dark 16 in
use code after dark 16 for up to 16 free
meals again guys it's hella fresh
america's number one meal kid
love you
so much of a
[Music]
okay
let's go
[Music]
already the best uh adrienne music and
zach managed to improve upon it even
more oh yeah dude that dude our sub
count is [ __ ] down bad
guys
no this is exciting though okay go ahead
because there is a good chance we're
down at a thousand you guys there's a
very good chance today is the day
that we hit
three million subscribers on the h3
podcast channel let's hear it everybody
guys guys we're going to vegas to
celebrate amy's birthday let's make it a
magical trip by hitting our big
milestone we've been reaching for this
for a long time
i think we're going to finally maybe do
it today do you want to read every
million subscribers that's all i want
for my birthday
do you want me to do the tagline ethan
the promo show
hit him with it all right everybody
thank you so much for tuning in we do
appreciate it we love you and you're
looking beautiful today so please make
sure to subscribe like the video turn on
that notification and we're gonna have a
good old time aren't we everybody can i
get a round of applause
[Music]
[Applause]
but it works great i can't wait
yeah and up next this was evil's joke
and up next can we get the bride and the
groom on the dance floor
we'll be doing the first dance here
ladies and gentlemen
let's consummate the dance floor like
they're gonna consummate later ladies
and gentlemen the bride and groom that's
inappropriate come on now
let's get uncle uh
let's get uncle bob out here to jizz on
the dance floor like the bride and groom
later tonight
we gotta slick up the floor somehow
get those oils pumping baby
yeah so i think you guys gotta just
resign to the fact that
um
we're gonna run out of people to
subscribe like what it went up like 20.
we're a thousand off bro
it's a formula the foreign part of this
formula is not saying how far away we
are
there's
there's no people they're all subbed
we're out of people
listen i know this game i've been doing
this a long time
i'm kidding
all right you guys get your mom's
listening
listening
yep
we do we do great with the aunts
i love us
i need some more spray my throat's
tickling
is it going
yeah it's getting a tickle in it
i gotta say that the act of spraying
something to back your though is not
that pleasant
ah i just
like it's really sweet
sweet yeah cherry flavored or something
but i don't like that it's sweet
i don't like tasting stuff with my
[ __ ] uvula
yeah the sensation is nice though
um all right let's talk about this dirty
dom [ __ ]
so dom's an idiot
i mean that's actually calling dom an
idiot is actually
um
it's actually like
being really generous to him
he's so much worse than that
yeah i crashed my brand new tesla you've
seen this clip all over social media i
crashed my brand new wait hold on i
forgot to do something
nice
got to find a hundred thousand dollars
from los angeles county made the news
and even the cops show wait is that for
real you gotta find a hundred thousand i
was i was just listening to the laugh
sound from
wally let's start over i highly doubt he
got fine yeah i don't believe that
constantly full of [ __ ] yeah
you've seen this clip all over social
media i crashed my brand new tesla gotta
find
a hundred thousand dollars in los
angeles county made the news
and even the cops showed up to my door
and the craziest part about this
none of it was real we knew that bro
everybody knew that this is the story of
how a boring saturday night turned me
into a viral wanted criminal i saw my
friend alex troy posted some great uh
prank that he did on everybody criminal
what is that
you pranked yourself for the second time
actually he's a viral monster yeah he
definitely pranked himself there
like i said everybody knew it was fake
within like the first couple hours his
video
like i posted i th the first time i saw
it was dirty dom and i saw casey posted
on twitter and i was like yeah it was
sturdy dom and then people were like nah
it's fake and i erased my comment
but yeah
i mean it was somewhat believable
because um
he
we we've talked about on the show he
like
likes to
do weird things implying like he's still
associated with david you know what i
mean and
it's like he was recreating the david
stunt
um so that was somewhat believable but
yeah it got debunked pretty quickly
video after doing some digging we were
able to get another angle from someone
that was there that night and if i was
one of the first few people to post it
by the way he
such an idiot that angle was from the
original video he just showed
yeah not some digging you [ __ ] it was
from the original video we go viral by
the way real quick side note i'm getting
a lot of um super chats saying do not
swallow that medicine you're not
supposed to swallow it you're supposed
to spray it and then spit it [ __ ]
how am i not supposed to swallow it goes
right down my throat i don't know ethan
don't swallow that medicine if you reach
the back you're supposed to switch it
and then spit it out
spray multiple times and then spit it
out trust me when i was young i drank it
and got very sick
hang on
has applied to the affected area one
spray
allowed to remain in place for at least
15 seconds then spit out
this is not i can't [ __ ] believe this
i'm not a doctor i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
spit out
what
oh no i wish someone told me that
that product is so stupid
to like squirt it in the back of your
throat so it ricochets into your stomach
and then puke it out afterwards
oops
thank you chat
won't be swallowing anymore though
spit it out
this is the second time this has
happened in the last few months
you put that cream on your face and that
product is dangerous
i guess
safe to assume most people would read
how to use yeah maybe i don't know the
directions
on over-the-counter directions nobody
reads that
great
well
thank you uh yeah thank you shout outs
who uh donated too thank you
thank you peace and love
peace and love
it's hot i'm writing it and i'm saying
it's hot we need ac
okay gotcha i'm hot [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
i'm hot [ __ ]
oh that's hot
all right let's get back to our story
now i have a tesla myself but it's not
black like in the original video and i
think it's the smaller model but with
some hollywood magic and good angles we
were able to make it look like my car
what do you mean you think it's the
smaller model [ __ ] you know what car
you have
he's embarrassed he has a model three
i think it's the smaller model
smaller model but with some hollywood
magic and good angles we were able to
make it look like my car was that car
now if there's one thing i know the
internet loves controversy they always
want a villain more controversy means
more comments
he's got this narrative where he's like
i'm pretending to be the villain
that's why everybody hates me right yeah
that's why nobody cared about this no
hollywood magic bro
he's like yo somebody was like brutally
like uh killed a whole family and i
threw some movie magic
to pretended that it was me
and it's dude and the police are so dumb
they came looking for me bro and they
arrested me
[ __ ] morons got him
such an epic prank
yeah so i'm just pretending to be the
villain guys
more comments means more engagement and
more engagement equals more fame wow is
he like stephen hawkings or something
that equation was insanely complicated
i was like crazy bro she'd be a
theoretical physicist definitely
now the voices didn't match in the video
and we did our own voice over and
reactions to make the video a little bit
more realistic we edited our clips
sprinkled in some hollywood magic and
posted it i wake up to 20 missed calls
hundreds of texts of people blowing me
up and six million views on this tick
tock video i was getting destroyed in
the comments people were calling me
reckless amenities society this had
blown up way bigger than i thought
instagram pages were posting the video
you guys were calling me a menace to
society but it's not true huh
it wasn't true before this either right
this is so stupid
dirty dirty dom might be the dumbest
person on the internet
dirty dumb you gotta keep watching you
gotta see his big conclusion oh there's
a big there's a big reveal millions of
views across different pages twitter was
having a field day with me roasting me
like a shish kebab and then
mama we made the news a tick tock handle
of
dominkus or dirtam from changing one
clip to another with no context we
fooled all of america
of course because why would somebody
pretend yeah to be the perpetrator of a
crime
like it's not difficult
nobody else is trying to take cred in
fact the person who actually did do it
is still on the lamb i think
yeah as far as i know they have not uh
captured the
perpetrator
with a little bit of movie magic
i was able to convince people that i am
the
golden state killer
it's not that
impressive dude confessed to a crime
that you didn't do
yeah that's bizarre it's like why would
you want to do this
he's going to explain shortly his point
and all this hmm yo there'll be like
criminals who've been in jail for 30
years for like double homicides yo bro
this was just a social experiment to
fool you guys
it actually i didn't do it
atla tmz nbc everyone was fooled this
goes to show you you can't believe
everything you see online in the social
media world if there's one thing i
learned it's 90 [ __ ] and percent
real those are the things you see hey
dude you are the [ __ ]
yeah i mean they were just showing your
video you didn't fool anyone right like
they were just reporting on what you put
out there
what a stupid song
are fake and meant to get clicks just
like this video because more clicks
means more money and everybody loves
money this proves that with the right
words the right angles and just enough
social proof you can make people believe
anything even the reporter who wrote an
article about my sexual accusations
he goes there he goes there
he's serious bro you actually
you did that
you [ __ ] did that bro
oh
baby even for a dirty dumb yeah
i didn't think it would be this dumb to
go
dirty dumb to make this
at that link that link he's like bro
they bought this story obviously my
other thing that is corroborated by
everybody there was fake accusations
fell for the story and dragged my name
you know what dude wow dumb you gotta
disappear after this
well
you may
get your wish um he was banned off a
tick tock a few hours ago oh
what happened to your epic prank bro
yeah it's it's so epic i got my social
media band it's so cool that's like joey
salads epic level
like joey salads epic prankster pretty
sure he's banned off every platform now
what is he even showing here hi dom this
is kat
the nbc news reporter i want to reach
out about the tesla stunt that went
viral that's a little desperate on cat's
part i have to say like
like
you can't really believe he's going to
talk to you
i
before you say that about it it could be
fake that could definitely you know what
you're right i don't know why yeah i i
wouldn't put that on her
yeah
but at the same time i do believe that
for some reason
similar to those accusations there was
no legal actions that happened against
me seeing a five second clip online is
not gonna give you the whole story so
before you jump to conclusions just
think for a second now i don't know who
was driving that car i wasn't even there
that night but i wanted to help some of
the folks out that got their cars
damaged jordan hook was one of the
neighbors living on that street that got
his subaru damaged i linked his gofundme
down below i donated some money to him
so if you got how much should he donate
let's take a look
that's so misleading that he's comparing
this to the article it's like
absolutely nothing to do one with the
unhinged thing to say it's it's it's
it's nuts like i would i would even get
if he was doing some kind of
subconscious push towards that point you
don't i'm sorry he donated 200
200 cool
could have been worse
because i noticed he said some money so
i was curious yeah like 10 bucks or
something
dude i think swallowing that [ __ ] me
up bro oh my stomach's going numb and
i'm burping like crazy oh my god not
again
oh my god
tips canceled again guys
[Music]
you guys want to help them out i would
appreciate it a lot i was editing the
video and this happened
oh there's someone here for our video
and did you have a cat in the car no no
there's no cat i don't have a cat thank
you
[Laughter]
oh my god you're stupid you really think
you're david dobrik oh my god i'm here
live that's not dude that's totally like
a recreation of that jared leto joker
scene where he's
[Laughter]
good his reporter came to interview him
and then
he told him to [ __ ] off and then he was
rolling and laughing so if you guys like
why is he so i appreciate it a lot why
is he so surprised it's like you you
confessed to a crime confessed to a
crime
and so people came to ask you about it
huh got him
[ __ ] owned you
weird
i was editing the video and this
happened
oh there's someone here for our video
and did you have a cat in the car no no
there's no cat i don't have a cat thank
you
then i saw myself on 10 o'clock news
this is tick-tock
bro you know that you're wanted right
boys
why would he have knives i just can't go
over how dumb that choker character is
meticulously placed knives in a semi
circle
he's joker branded
they're just joker things dude
dom is so like desperate for attention
this this is wild
this really is wild well it's backfiring
because now he's getting kicked off of
social media
and he was the driver of the tesla but
we made it on the news
that he made the news and that the
police are offering a reward for the
driver of the rented tesla are you
saying you were the driver of the chest
of the oven man it's crazy out there man
i don't know what was going on
um you know some people are saying that
you are that you're just claiming that
you are on social media yeah wow it's
like they even called you out there yeah
oh my lord they're just like are you
really this dumb like yeah did you do
that
don't you see that people saw right
through your dumb little joke oh my god
don't be careful out there
and did you have a cat in the car no no
there's no part of that
why is that funny she literally called
you out
the media likes to capitalize on the
downfall of public figures and if they
don't have a story to attack they'll
just create one don't believe everything
you see online you did that even right
now we're about to post a video and
i go to my tick tock and it says this
guy's like i try to search my name they
literally deleted my whole verified tick
tock account wow
usually when they get your account
deleted you can appeal it or you can
like submit a reason it doesn't even
give me a reason it just says download
your data that's all it says so someone
higher up must have literally deleted my
account without questioning anything
just from seeing
these news articles online guys this is
[ __ ] nuts this shows you just how
corrupt how [ __ ] up everything is
oh my gosh what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
your brain is corrupt you really drove
that point home huh
so interesting on everything so corrupt
because you're a [ __ ] menace dude and
then they said well i'll just erase this
guy is he still erased on tick tock yeah
god bless i hope that they actually
keep it that way
it looks like they will i mean what do
they care about dom
which is great
he was tick tock was one of the only
platforms he was finding success because
he was doing a lot of videos where he
couldn't see his face
and he was getting a lot of views so he
really so this epic uh
prank really backfired on him yeah
oh the whole world is owned
everybody by him
want to smell some farts
let's go not particularly
all right so past the uh boxy
so amaranth we had spoken
about her she's been bottling farts
and we said you should send us some
farts
also i had said you know i think this
was my idea
i wanted to take credit as an ideas man
and she wrote a note here i'm gonna read
to you guys it says hey
gang thank you so much for the great
idea
hey
[Music]
i'm an ideas man
you are you are
i give
you know
this is all i ask for in return it's
just a nice note and a jar of farts
if you have any more please let me know
well i will love your friend amaranth
wow
that's nice
and then of course here in the box the
cuties patooties mm-hmm
oh yeah whoa there's four jars in each
one there's four enough yeah there's
four jars in each box we have eight jars
of farts that's my dudes enough for the
whole gang wait there's two boxes of
four each yeah yeah that's another
number
oh wait this one has water in it oh bath
water uh-oh she also does bath water too
okay
yeah so that's bath water and this is
the fart so she has the oh she has the
numbers 17 of
3 000. but her bathwater is like
blue
like a bath bomb or something you think
she bath bombed huh
chunks in there eh
that's a little weird
yeah there's some chunks in there for
sure okay so the bathwater
i'm not gonna make you guys drink
anything that's well yeah i saw people
drinking um
people drink this um
somebody yeah what's your name
yeah people were drinking her bath water
like they were
which is even more sustainable so thick
so here we've got the farts
oh my god somehow i can tell there's
just
oh there's a hair in it too i forgot you
did that
he puts a single hair in there
four jars of parts
and it's numbered
wait can i ask you a question all right
did we the jar she sent us are number
15 16 17 and 18 does that mean that she
only sold 14
i don't know what possibly is this
produced yeah is it
how much is the fart is it a thousand i
think it's a thousand bucks maybe the
first like 20 were saved for friends or
something
it's probably a thousand bucks though is
it a better value if it's the lower
number out of one thousand oh absolutely
if we had one of one i would say don't
open it
it's like this item we have 15 16 17
18 and 18.
it's pretty good pretty good that's
respect
i mean maybe she did only sell that many
but
let's i mean that's still what
14 grand
for just
a jar is it a thousand per jar and she
sent us four thousand per jar and then
100 for the bath water
so she sent us four thousand dollars
worth of farts here wow she's a legend
and then four hundred dollars worth of
bath water yup wow whoa
could this appreciate value do you think
somebody in the chat said the miz kiff
got number one
did he open it [ __ ] i believe so i saw
yeah i saw a clip what an idiot why
would he open number one
[Laughter]
can't open number one
he got one two three and four so yeah it
sounds like the the early numbers were
yeah for friends yeah
all right so then let's go with the 18
so zach you're going to be smelling this
right or a b did you say i can do it we
can hey jb for his birthday
whatever he wants lena already gave her
blessings yeah
now what i want you to be looking for
when you're smelling this
is basically
i want you to be looking for
earthy tones rudy tones okay mostly i
want you to be
looking for if you think it's a fart
spray
or a real human a human stink
okay okay
[Music]
okay so here's number 18. it's got one
here in there
[Music]
damn we got hooked up though
somebody said i'm gonna have a pink guy
for vegas talk about it leading up to
this okay yeah
now
my my assumption is that if you fart it
in a jar
and then closed it i think the smell
wouldn't last necessarily
that's an interesting point yeah we were
wondering the same thing at least i was
but but we should that would be my
inclination too but but
the only reason
i think otherwise is i like i said i saw
that clip of mischief smelling it but
that's why i think maybe it's a fart
spray
how could a
that's a
that's a big accusation that's fraud
what you're saying actually it might not
be fraud that actually might be fraud
like actual fraud i mean if you're
selling it for well that's art actually
i don't think you can defrost
yeah i don't think so because it's art
okay well if you're like yo i spent a
thousand dollars on this far and you
sent me a fart spray i'm suing you
no it's art
yeah here someone hand me a jar real
fast
come on
come on i want a mess today yeah you're
just like no i'm going to spit it out on
this
dan what do you think i need it
shouldn't take a break from this i'm not
going to swallow it if you don't swallow
it i think it's okay lena bought the
medicine
all right guys here's how it's supposed
to work apparently
oh god it's so gross
come on
it still swallows them i don't know how
you don't swallow it that's why i was
saying take a break from it
because it's really deep down my throat
so how can i get it it's like past the
point of no return you know what i mean
yeah that's a good point now my whole
mouth is numb
oh god
all right you ready abe yeah
okay so get it get a good close-up now
now get
move your mic or something i don't i
want the shot to be perfect yeah
okay
bottoms up no wait wait wait oh bring it
closer to your nose i don't want you to
miss it yeah okay don't wanna miss big
snip big sniff
okay he sniffed the fart he took a big
big
he's going back for a second i think
he likes it now he took a big inhale the
first time
and he's thinking it over
he's tasting it licking his
it's
it's bad
but i can tolerate it
that makes me think it might be legit
because if it's like a if it's like a
part spray or whatever it would be like
real nasty right
yeah it would be can i maybe
well that one's gone wait it's out into
the east here you can give zach another
yeah i think you need a fresh here's
what seven number 17 for zach that's a
thousand bucks you guys owe
me take it out of your paycheck
so maybe does it like smell like a real
fart like
you break that down for me how fresh
does it smell
it
it smells aged a little bit did it smell
like farts it wasn't what i was
expecting huh
in what way
no i kind of want zach to smell it okay
i want to see his reaction before okay
now wait wait wait just just okay get
the shot right move the mic a little
okay okay get right in there so it
doesn't fly away
hey go ahead
yeah i'll get it get it in there yeah
when you
yeah
okay zach is he's nose deep
seems unfazed actually
huh
zach put his whole nose in there doesn't
smell like anything oh
well that makes me think it's real it is
real then yeah
how do you fart so much how do you fart
a thousand times on command
well we uh didn't we just didn't we just
talked about this recently yeah that
woman that yeah followed her farts and
she was eating like bean paste and [ __ ]
90 day fiancee she did so much she like
got sick and had to get a heart attack
i don't think amaranth is doing that i
wonder if she's like hot boxing at home
and then just just airing the whole
thing yeah dude i got a dud i'm
disappointed here here past sack number
16. fine
you can give him two grand worth of fun
yeah you owe me 2k
shredder
you got to ask shredder's permission
before you approach jb
okay so zach put his whole nose in there
he got a dud he claims
good thing she sent us four bottles four
it doesn't smell like anything so zach
is queuing up his new um
his new jar i want to smell it with you
i'm going to av and zach are going to be
smelling together now
a romantic moment
okay ready
okay go ahead hold your nose in there
okay
[Music]
it's a dude
[Music]
in number i wonder if she just had some
really
kind of
what did you smell like
one more one more
zach you're not getting paid this month
in fact you're gonna owe me money
[Music]
all right so this is our final jar real
quick what scent did you smell if you
could describe it
a shy angel
a shy angel
jesus yeah
okay there was a little bit in that one
let damn don't don't talk at all a.b
i think there was a little like methane
aroma that i picked up
so four thousand dollars worth of farts
later
um
zach what do you what did you think
about all that
is it a worth a grand i mean love
amaranth you know support over content
but
i don't i you're disappointed i'm
disappointed
look you got a pretty good sniff the
first time maybe i got duped dude well
he got that birthday snip so he can have
it yeah i don't know there was a little
something in the first one yeah the
other one seemed to be duds but we still
got her hair so there is still
some value in there we'll clone her and
get yeah
wait is there is there
owning one of this
it's like you said it's art it is art
yeah
no hair in mind
everyone's saying that ab just vacuumed
up all the smell that's what i think he
was he was hugging
yeah you guys yeah he's getting called
out i saw that right now you guys tell
him get in there get a really good smell
and then when he does it you tell him
you're way too into it no
no i said i just mean where's
no i said av get a good smell when on
his turn okay then when it's zac started
me going in there
but
you still want him to i'm not smelly i
didn't smell anything i was trying to
get something i was trying i felt like
you know this is a thousand dollars i
give a bad reaction and i thought maybe
i give a good reaction if i actually
smell something yeah and i didn't smell
anything well should we get more jars
from her should i i want a real nasty
one we gotta do this live man with her
she's gonna find
so
did we do this live on the show when we
were doing this i don't remember but
lena gave
a b permission to get it was after the
show oh and ass yeah i said yeah i said
is she cup because
she was in l.a she was like hey you want
to do something
and i said let forget the jar you come
fart in evie's face wow and lena was
like
yeah she was enthusiastically a yes from
lino well elena is the best right lena
yeah she said yeah yeah
no coercion
confident
confident queen unbelievable that's true
i just think it'd be cool like you know
if anyone back home is like what do you
do for a living and i show them that
clip of me smelling ass
that's what i [ __ ] do
i didn't notice but the the hair in here
too
i didn't do that
do you listen to this show i do but i i
didn't see it we mentioned it like
right but it's so small
like you have to take a few looks at it
will you taste the hair
[Laughter]
that is examining the hair don't do it
he's about to eat it
yeah he's tasty oh
nasty
bro but um would you let amreth fart my
face just
i mean after lena i have to follow early
that can't be the really the sour one
here yeah i don't i don't i'm not
looking for it but i was just curious
about where your boundary is
if i didn't have lena's context i don't
know how i would react but i don't think
you would let me get forward in my face
it's a little weird it's a different
situation what's worse so lap dance or
or smelling a fart
and lapis is worse obviously would you
let me get a lap dance
no oh do some titties interesting you
pre yeah right i mean i approached that
from the wrong
angle there i don't i wouldn't i was
just curious fart is more like um
educational right
a little
nature uh nature it's research
scientific okay what about this what
about if it wasn't on the show
oh no came over to the house no
hell
hell
no
okay so what's his worst because then it
would be like you got some weird fetish
that i need to get to the bottom
which is worse
you have to choose yeah amaranth comes
to the house
parts of my face immediately leaves who
well the question is who initiated it
me me this is something you were seeking
i said hey will you come she said why
are you busy i say you come by stop by
far my face real fast
and in this hypothetical are you the h3
guy and she's the twitch girl say yes
okay but it's not it's not televised or
anything okay but is it still for the
show no
no that's a
problem it's not a secret but i tell you
i think yeah amy is stopped by she
farted my face and left okay
[Laughter]
or a lap dance where i come in my own
pants
what
what is wrong with you
you missed too much you missed the
stripper call
there we had a whole call
i still didn't listen to that episode so
which is worse hold on i'm coming
at what context are you doing the lap
dance
like just with the guys we go out and
then maybe it's my birthday and go eat
good olympians and then i end up
creaming my own pants jesus christ
the [ __ ] is this conversation
i mean i'm not doing any of it i'm just
curious where the boundary is say it's
like the weekend we're in vegas yeah
we're exactly you know i would not be
okay with that though
i know you guys have to choose you gotta
choose i'm gonna do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
in a way is like in my head more normal
behavior
definitely right so but it's also really
bad so
but if you if the the fart one was
actually a situation i would be like who
is this guy that i married because i
don't know that
i think guy farting is worse right yeah
because it's more of an intimate thing
where it's like yeah bomb fart my face
the lap i mean lap dances is like
you don't want to mess with me you know
it happens listen to her
all right who would you rather have sex
with your i'm just kidding
okay just curious you know
what's saying you're saying just
well there you have it amaranth's farts
can be purchased at cutie
cutiepatooty.me
for 999
and you get a card of certification
oh it's after dark number 69
69
yo screaming my pants baby yo
yo 69 thank you trump
69. um
something else i wanted to do oh the
enemies of the show to your list
[Music]
this seems fun
so
do you want this
situation sodapop a little soda yeah i
take a little saudi
like a little shmody
you want to share the saudi i'll hit
that your own cop
whatever i'm easy
um
so
okay now dan this is in the dark you got
a problem with this huh what do you mean
would always be closing oh ryan posted
this
no no no i'm sorry
uh the bull posted the first one brad
the bull posted yes
is that okay dan
[Music]
that's awesome
let me see that again
[Music]
who drew that uh you know what i wish i
remember it was literally drawn for the
show five years ago this was like 27
that's why it's the old uh style of
graphic as well um you know with that
like beige background
um it was somebody on the subreddit is
it
is way too long ago but if you're
watching shout out we still have it and
uh got some use about it
so brad the bull posted this
it's uh
ryan's wife
you got any of those sound effects
no i can pull something yeah we need
lots of brad the ball sound effects
um
frank kevin is like the uh
inquistador is that what you call him
are you talking about matador yeah
matador okay he's the kakador
yeah he's like the matador that gets hit
by the ball immediately
so anyway um they're in vegas apparently
right now with james charles
which is
i mean dan has this theory of the legion
of doom that all enemies of the show are
converging it started as a joke but i
i i genuinely think they're up to
something
[Music]
he is suing me four times already is
that is more than that
uh
right but that's just ryan i'm saying
like like this is this is like they're
getting the dream team together
by the way what do you think about
james's fit ela do you have any comments
on that
um
that's
kind of cute oh [ __ ]
there you go socks
it gives me the creeps i don't know
well he just he gives me exactly
it gives me the heebie-jeebies
yeah you didn't ask me about him thank
you
yeah really sad
it's my favorite one
anyway ryan said under this post no i'm
sorry it's not under this post i should
have labeled it properly this is just
another example of the legion of doom
where fousey fousey's commenting on a
post of ryan's
okay so you got james
and
uh
whatever his wife
and then fousey's commenting under ryan
spouse but fousey and keem have uh this
collab with them that's what i'm saying
though it's all it's all coalescing is
it all of them it tastes like beef jerky
there's been way too many
crossovers
so
yep
um
so anyway in the spirit of them all
coming together we thought we'd do a
uh
enemy of the show tier list yeah the
original was actually posted by fan on
the subreddit uh we happened to see it
this week
um wow we made a lot of faces yeah we
made some modifications oh my god
additions some subtractions
what
yo this is way too many well yeah we're
gonna do these we can bust through them
wait why is ian on here
why am i i was confused by that ian's on
here myself is on here i could
definitely see that one
we were talking about the self-sabotage
but why even ian shouldn't be here i
mean it's kind of a meme that like ian
hates his life and doesn't want to be
here i'm on there
you guys didn't need to scrape the
bottom of the barrel so much we have so
many enemies of the show
well again we did not actually make the
original oh this is this is a fan
generated uh
thing we did we did some tweaks we did
some removal some additions here and
there but this this was a
uh community generated tier okay
okay well let's let's just um
let's just dig right into it
bts like the band yeah oh are you
kidding me forgiven i can do no wrong
why are they even on here bts forever
stan bts stan june stan uh
june right the other one of them
probably
stan all those [ __ ] they're the
greatest more of a
more of a black pink guy myself so i
like v sh i like both
i stand them both
would you like a b
b
v
oh he's the best yeah
[Music]
love those guys
tell everyone you know h3 loves
bts
it's k-pop in general i love bts
shout it from the rooftop let the whole
world know
[Music]
k-pop forever
demi lovato
um she's not an enemy of the show i mean
cringe but harmless yeah that's fair
that's a good guy yeah
i mean
soflo
he's not really a threat but
i mean he did scam people out of fake
masks at the beginning of the pen he did
also threaten to sue us back during the
i think jail was pretty appropriate yeah
actually he really should be in jail
if you go way back he was threatening to
sue us him and his body right when we
were in new york and that was um one of
our first scares legal scares yeah
jason nash honestly
this is a tough one for me i want to put
him in forgiven i don't say i i mean i
don't say we were wrong
cringy but and you couldn't even say
that he's harmless because of like the
seth stuff
the seth stuff makes it complicated
because on one hand i want to forgive
him
because i feel like trisha filled my
mind with lies
but on the other hand you have to
remember what happened with seth
but it is right or die for the david
situations in general so
while he may seem harmless he's
definitely like
by proxy yeah right sort of and don't
forget he was like jeff is going to love
this apollo this video
i guess he's going to be deleted trash
unfortunately jason
i don't want to put you there
but i think your hands are tied
if you if you if you just use your brain
and not your heart that's where you
belong and i'm very sorry but
wait shredder why is shredder enemy of
the show because he always interrupts
he's trying to sabotage but yeah he's
forgiven he's a perfect angel we were
wrong legend
legend status forgiven forgiven forgiven
again forgiven forgiven absolutely i
forgive shredder 20 times a day
who's this the um
that's the prince fam
yeah right it's really small on my
screen
yeah they're the ones with the click
bait where their kids have like
their kids are like dying
i would say straight to trash
was it
i'm kind of leaning towards cringey but
harmless
i mean i guess they exploded i don't
remember their stuff enough
we did a whole content club on with
yeah i mean she was having like a fake
uh miscarriage yeah yeah yeah oh that
was really funny yeah yeah that was
really fun no they're they're trash yeah
okay fair enough
okay so aidan ross
i gotta put straight to jail yeah
because once again just a crim he
actually is a criminal but
he is the chosen one
what he did to keemstar was yeah
oh yeah sure you're in trouble that
crypto i say cringey but harmless maybe
just because of the keem thing
is he he's not hungry when you're
involved the gambling stuff yeah yeah
you do the gambling
harmless it's not
yeah
that crypto [ __ ] you know aidan ross he
seems like a decent kid he's very young
but all the gambling stuff he does is
just horrible
i mean
he is so young that i mean i don't want
to say let him off the hook but like i
could see him just like getting caught
up in
lifestyle and everything really easily i
think i think him destroying keem
you know bumps him down in here you know
what i say middle tier maybe deleted
trash yeah exactly right they're not
harmless but it's not straight to jail
yeah
but technically i do think he there's a
good case
yeah right right which you know
but okay he gets a he gets a bonus point
yeah
gary vee is uh
i think deleted trash
yeah
he's not harmless
and he's not straight to jail it's kind
of weird to put somebody at the top
because i don't know that we can say
that we wish death on anybody we don't
wendy williams does
i know but even if um just by taking it
out of context should i change it what
should i say
death yeah uh what's another i think we
should change it another way i'm not
gonna feel comfortable putting anybody
there oh there's some i will banish to
the shadow realm
death to all jews
you sure there's no one you could think
to put there
no
not anything that i would say
on the show we shouldn't wish death on
anyone i'm not it's a windy i know it's
a meme but yeah but
it could be clipped out of context okay
so then you can say
um death irredeemable vile scum
yeah yeah that's a little harsh
not that funny deleted fat people are
saying delete it
i like that all of them
i know you like it we all like how about
clap if you want them to die
no oh clap if you or clap if you want
them to suffer clap if you want that was
the original quote yeah yeah okay that's
that's more mild you want me to type it
dan
uh you have to yeah
clap if you want them too she should
suffer what is the wording clap if they
should suffer yeah something like that
play it against that cheeks
all right clap if you think she should
suffer
if you think they should
there's also this one too if you've ever
wanted to kill somebody
and you know what i'm even gonna put
wendy williams in case some kids try to
take it out of context
williams okay yeah speaking of which
it's not in the doc for today but we'll
have to talk about it next it's coming
back right
no there's like a crazy update with her
really really yeah she said she was
coming back and then what happened she
posted a video where
she
is saying that these people are trying
to forcibly put her into a
conservatorship and she's locked out of
all of her money and stuff and like the
video is actually very
calm and coherent when she's explaining
what's going on it's a kind of believer
um
i don't know we need to look into it
more because i was just seeing it this
morning very windy yeah i don't think
we're ready for another conservatorship
right they should just be not ready
they should just put a pause on any
conservatorship yo free windy right now
bro seriously after what happened to
britney spears can we all agree that the
idea is kind of messed up just saying i
mean it makes sense in a very narrow set
of circumstance
yeah but seeing what was possible to
happen to her within those circumstances
is not okay yeah it only makes sense to
me in the case of someone who's like
totally
um senile amanda bynes just was freed
from yeah that's insane like what the
[ __ ] yeah i mean i
why aren't only women by the way who get
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] right
at least at least on a high profile
basis yeah it does
seem to be a pattern doesn't it
i mean this was something we talked
about before but where's all the like
high-powered men being thrown in
conservative ships it doesn't happen
and there's plenty of crazy ones kanye
west
martin sheen
wait charlie charlie
you know i'm saying it's [ __ ] yeah
all right let's continue this is our boy
uh what's his name
this is jeff's friend
who came to our house cody hey cody
listen i would never go against the
family i'm putting you here so you don't
come to my house
you're forgiven baby let me give you a
kiss
don't you ever come to my house again
what's his name again cody cody cody go
to you don't ever come to my house again
i love you like a brother
that's the kiss of death you understand
don't let it happen twice
you're forgiven
i'll never happen again
you're part of the family now what was
his name again
are you serious
[Laughter]
[Music]
cody you're one of us
you're one of the good fellas
[Music]
cody's forgiven
[Music]
who the [ __ ] is this here um can you
zoom in a little bit
yeah yeah wait who's this
oh my that's that comedian isn't it the
one that
oh
who the [ __ ] is that yeah
we talked about a long time ago sam
tripoli thank you kim wait he was the
guy that just like randomly went on like
a like a really energetic rant about
what a piece of [ __ ] you are with um
wasn't it with the covet stuff or a
vaccine oh right it was
uh because you talking about the vaccine
with the joe rogan thing with brian
calvin yeah brian was on it
and uh i guess i don't remember
when when everybody freaked out that
ethan was saying is more fit than joe
rogan it wasn't that it was not before
it was before that yeah it was near the
beginning of the pendant when i was
being like yo people get vaccinated and
don't gather in large crowds and then i
was like get a load of this [ __ ]
obvious
all right actually i mean the fact that
he
we barely even remember
i
uh don't recognize i'd say cringy but
harmless
yeah that's who cares that's true
nikita dragon
cringey but harmless definitely i don't
really know much about it
i don't know much about her either so
forgive me if it's like she killed
someone or something
[Laughter]
i'mma get cancelled i can't believe
ethan put nikita dragon and cringy but
harmless
[Music]
who's this zach or jimmy lee
or there's the keemstar kid oh it's the
keep star kid
cringey that's right enemy of the show
definitely uh crunchy but harmless
that's funny
dude how are these all gonna fit they're
not they're not good or not there's too
many
that's true
dave pork boy
uh cringy but harmless
as far as i know allegedly i mean i
don't know whatever happened with all
those allegations allegedly harmless
yeah allegedly harmlessly
you have a you want to move them up dan
i mean the those allegations were pretty
serious but i but it's true i i have not
seen any follow-up on that i don't know
i know it was getting litigated in the
courts so
i mean he also
uh we had we had another uh beef with
him at one point right
boy he was mean to trisha i mean
he was mean to trisha
at first yeah you think we started a war
b yeah yeah
yeah whatever then
yeah i think we don't know enough about
that one i don't know why pyrocynicles
here so i'm putting on the bottom i
don't know why ian's here
i'm putting him on the bottom thank you
jake paul
uh jake paul
huh i think oh man straight to jail yeah
he's kind of done it all he's done it
all he's done the [ __ ] he's done the cs
go scam boxes
he's got has the allegations
these essay allegations uh he got kicked
out of l.a
yeah
you know he might even be responsible
for the lawsuits i'm going through he
might actually clap if they you think
they should suffer right yeah
also every day bro
i think he's the
the ultimate crime i think it's clap if
you think he should suffer i think we
have our friend i think we might have
our first talk
[ __ ] did you ever say that his covet
[ __ ] though oh yeah we don't care bro we
don't care
well that was that logan
they weren't bothered
well he called them both it was on the
same page it was this kid tanner fox
yeah who got kovit and he called them
it's the same video yeah they were both
seen also in like having like parties
during the worst time of covid yeah
friends of the show though he has been
on the podcast
joe nipple
joe protrusion nipple i think it's
cringy but harmless
you know to go cut him a little slack
pro jared
argued
because like what are you promoting all
that iron [ __ ] yeah i don't know all
right all right that's true deleted
trash
yeah he's he kind of goes with gary vee
a little bit in that
pro jared wow that's a throwback this is
controversial i think he's deleted trash
a lot of people forgive him i don't
because he
don't ever forget he has a forum for his
fans to uh
have adult conversations with him yeah
called sin jared yeah it's funny that
might be straight i personally find it
very creepy
yeah i remember when that all happened
people got mad at us for being so hard
on him i don't think we were hard enough
like that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] up well
because he made this video that i guess
showed that one of the girls wasn't
being truthful about something and then
all the incels were immediately oh you
remember it was worse than that his like
way of waving it all off was explaining
that this person had mental health
problems really yeah and that was like
he was like you can't trust this person
they have mental health problems this
person that i
uh exchanged nudes with this underage
person
oh wait yeah there was they're like
blaming the victim hold on there was
like two trans
people who were accusing him of stuff
and then it i think it came out that
they were they were not being truthful
or something or that they weren't
trustworthy
so everyone was like yo he's innocent
everyone needs to do a pot and then all
the commentators were like you need to
apologize to pro jared yeah but he still
made the
whole page for him and his friends
sending nudes to each other yes san
jared that was not in debate and that
alone is creepy and unacceptable right
he's straight to jail
and he also cheated on his wife which
is not a jail thing add it to the pile
exactly
i mean that stuff happens that's
different i i get it but it's just kind
of like no no no the character of this
guy
milk boys are straight to jail
yeah
half center
alex jones straight to jail
[Music]
right or is he deleted trash
[Music]
uh i personally think he's suffering
really alex jones is a bad dude i mean
the sandy hook the harassing the hook
it's unforgivable to me yeah yeah i
don't care how much of a mimi is
isn't that just darling
he should suffer okay fouseytube is
definitely cringy but harmless
alfredo you should not be on here you're
forgiven
you have god's grace you remember
forgiven at birth
michaela peterson deleted trash
jeffree star with like an automatic
weapon i don't understand this deleted
trash
now obviously c-man is forgiven he's
done nothing wrong
yeah i don't know why he was on there
either c-man is is not a villain
it's pretty good all right
i guess okay it's pretty good foot it's
pretty good just in the guy's feet you
know it's pretty good it's not bad it's
not bad
you know it has some hair on it i'd give
it like a seat
with a little color you know with a
little tan
that's a pretty good foot i give it a i
give it a cam does it really good you
can even see man
cam hit us with your c-man
guys there's too many here there's too
many
i think zach's c-man takes the cake
though do you think zack's is better
than well i haven't
yeah he does do a good alex it's pretty
good i guess it's all right you know i i
i should suffer but with a foot you know
you know i like to uh i like to sniff
foots i like to get stepped on uh you
know
pretty good though pretty nice my
suffering is you know i like to blow my
load on guys feet you know it's a good
time
you know i got it all i got the foot i
got the big foot i got the big uh
yeah and you know what else is big
this is carlos and the crew where do you
where do we play sparrows in the crew
is there a godfather
that was
the most amazing interview
i don't know about lumping them together
because i don't think the the other
dudes were necessarily i'm gonna skip it
i'm gonna skip it but carlos i would say
rolo tony
that guy
give like i don't know straight to jail
yeah really he's straight to jake
he's done something to deserve it i
don't know what he did but
i agree
rolo tony browntown what are your
friends check yourself right into jail
rice gum
straight to jail
i'm just gonna skip these horrible ones
yeah okay that's fair
um chris monroe straight to jail
jordan peterson
the leader trash yeah that's fair
tim poole
[Music]
uh s deleted trash
too nice cringy but harmless
sure he only harms himself wiki feet and
shoe nice is a wild card because he at
various times he's been
an enemy and an ally to mm-hmm
depends on
yeah it's true like chaotic neutral yeah
exactly pure chaos
he's the joker
he really is the quartering is probably
uh straight to jail i mean the man shits
in his own [ __ ] drain
that's not a crime i don't know what it
is
[Laughter]
that's right
um thanks ethan banks is cringy but
harmless i'd say
the subreddit i'm not writing that
now logan paul
the celebrity depends on the day could
go in any of those categories
logan paul this is a tough one again
he's doing all the crypto stuff skip
crypto scams
it wasn't for that he'd probably be
deleted trash i'm a mother freaking blue
worried the dink joint kind of kicks it
up a notch a b i'm not raiding
roiling i'm not raiding keemstar
obviously
yeah uh clap if you think they should
suffer
need i explain no no really we hate
keemstar
ace family always straight to jail
yeah
14 pages
no that's too hard i don't even remember
cringey better than 48 pages what was he
talking about was was the ethan klein
film yeah
i wrote 14 pages
he was writing about uh 14 pages
meticulously
reactors are
damaging everything yeah he was doing i
don't have time for that it's a 14 page
document
14 pages
myself
asking her
you think you want me to suffer is
suffer i don't know if i'd say suffer
right whatever's
most
i mean dom is you know
i'm misconduct the worst right
yeah
yeah
he kind of he kind of goes on the top
yeah but i don't care about him that
much so it's kind of hard to say yeah
maybe
that's why i still don't care about alex
jones that much as far as the show goes
i'm sorry i gotta move alex jones down
yeah fair enough
you know yeah
[Music]
oliver tree
probably he's definitely clap if you
think they should suffer right
shane dawson this picture is so funny
uh shane is
i think he's just
deleted trash yeah
i know some people really hate his guts
but
my dad
he's forgiven
yeah he's forgiven
why the [ __ ] is
patrice wilson here that doesn't make
any sense no it's not patrice wilson yes
it is patrice o'neil
why is patrice
so
we were very confused as well
and
ian realized that the primary place that
the person that created this was drawing
from was from the roast when ian did the
gag of the uh
pulling down all the giant list of
people that we've beefed with yeah and
ian accidentally wrote patrice o'neill
so whoever was making this was just
going off of ian's uh
goof
and then you've got uh leafy that's
interesting that's a name i haven't
heard in a while right
there should be a forgotten tab right
who's that who's that again literally
literally
um
honestly he's kind of leafy's kind of
cringy but harmless
yeah yeah
he's not actually done anything like if
you got bear in the keemstar or
something yeah he's really yeah
he's not as bad as all these other [ __ ]
hasn't he like threatened people
leafy threatened people i don't think so
that i know
okay i don't think so
just saying you know what
jeff i'm sorry i know people are gonna
be crazy about this but jeff is forgiven
i'm best friends with jeff again
okay and people say he bought the
alcohol or whatever jeff says the
alcohol was already there
well
jeff says was a good beginning to that
sentence
[Laughter]
jeff also says the
the article was [ __ ] right
uh he makes it so hard
where do i put this
whatever
where do i put this damn where should i
put this
don't don't even ask yeah
i don't even care i ain't touching this
one no tell me where it should be i'm
gonna touch it
and then it's right
i can't
you have you have a man crush on the man
i i can't i can't override that yes you
can i don't have a man crush on him i'm
just kidding i totally do
tell me where to put this somebody
uh
next to the other 30 that you skipped
yeah maybe just skip skip yeah yeah he's
not entering the show
uh vitaly i mean
vitaly belongs in jail definitely yeah
there's no question about that oh it
starts another line bryce hall cringy
but harmless
i don't know who the [ __ ] this is who's
this oh nearby james hey here by
[Laughter]
he was for like a little bit he went he
went off on trisha and then
yeah
right right a philip defranco
that one's like kind of just a joke
conclusion anna is cringy and harmless
she's not really enemy of the show is
she
not at all my cringy but harmless
ryan kavanaugh definitely clap if you
think they should suffer
[Music]
james charles i think is clap if you
think they should suffer
[Music]
and then lance stewart tough one between
jail and that on charles
[Music]
we never got to talk about it but
i think the podcast was on a break while
i was watching
cheer season two
but there is someone on cheer
the netflix documentary about
the cheerleaders there's someone on
there that pretty much did something
very similar to what james did
and he went straight to jail sorry i
thought that was interesting
what was he doing just talking to miners
he was soliciting
photos for minors yeah videos and
footage and pictures you're going to
jail buddy and um and then it escalated
one time when they were at the school
he kind of he
tried to
like be physical with one of the kids
i think the kids were like 13.
they were twins
but
but um nothing happened but he tried
and then i guess he got super famous
because of the show because cheer was
like huge
and then the kids
when they saw him all the time and how
big he was getting like being on oprah
and stuff like that talking to obama
things like that
they decided to tell their mom about it
and
the moms tried to file about it
everywhere and it kept getting ignored
and eventually i don't remember how we
got into the fbi
and they immediately
put put an end on it and locked him up
and they found like all the stuff on his
phone and things like that oh wow yeah
that's what i'm that's why i'm just so
confused why james charles is i guess
none of the parents somehow filed a
police report because i guess they need
that
but surely the fbi must have a file on
him it did show how it's not easy to get
your complaint like noticed she she went
through all the channels and nobody like
did anything about it
that's what i think too
no i'm not kidding the fbi must have a
file on james charles
[Music]
they might
i mean they must
so let's review
clap if you think they should suffer we
got jake paul keemstar oliver tree
kavkav and james girls that's a that's a
that's a strong circle right there yeah
other trees
the most deserving yeah put him in the
first spot
straight to jail is also really powerful
too yeah vitaly soflow projera nelk
rolo tony browntown
because that he's become a real enemy of
the show lately
got the rice gum prank invasion
quartering logan
ace family dom
yeah and alex jones this is a great
list down to the yeah the ones that we
didn't touch honestly i would say that
this is really the real enemies of the
show here
is just these three tiers
right
yeah anything below is kind of whatever
yeah um
you skipped uh you skipped um j station
i feel like j station needs to be up j
station
like straight to jail
j station is straight to jail
what the freak greg paul is straight to
jail oh yeah yeah yeah
michael jackson
michael jackson is definitely
how was michael jackson's not ending the
show
i feel like uh
mudahar we could put in the forgiven
yeah we kind of made a mess with him
definitely yeah
next to my dad
uh
i mean the trailer company i guess i
mean ryan kavanaugh is on there yeah
yeah
i mean i put him in the one star
category right
so there you have it okay that was fun
that was a good time for the list what a
fun time we have we have fun here on the
show don't worry we really do
um we are at an hour 51
so
pretty close to
wrap-up time here let me see if there's
anything
that we should go over members bts will
be delayed
oh i was wondering if we should do the
footage in vegas as uh ethan klein
upload
whatever you want it'd be fun right yeah
also um
you have kylie in the title what is that
about i have no idea
it was supposed to be just a quick hit
uh kylie jenner and travis scott changed
name of baby oh kylie made the
announcement explaining she and travis
just really didn't feel like the name
suits their son who is not yet seven
weeks old the baby's name was wolf
they're now they're rebranding the
baby's name is wolf
what no no no no that
that is the baby's current name is wolf
before the rebrand it was wolf it says
they haven't released they have not
released it oh
the baby has sponsors so they need to
get ahead of uh exactly the name change
wow they don't want to lose sponsors fy
our son's name isn't wolf anymore we
just really didn't feel like it was him
just wanted to share because i keep
seeing wolf everywhere
well that makes sense i guess if
everyone's like well if this well if
that
is that
it wasn't good for seo yeah is that just
no
bizarre word to compete on
if you want to seo name just name your
baby like something like
like ex
why right is that the name of elon
that's yeah that's why elon did that
yeah smart very smart it's marketing
what's it gotta do oh yeah you know that
their baby was born born the same day as
bruce
oh yeah
so if you guys aren't feeling bruised
yeah i was about to do a rebrand
thinking about welcome to the world wolf
jenner climb
we'll take the last name in the middle i
think i think jenna i think wolfe is
such a cool name like actually i
actually really like it i'll call you
wolf if you want zach yeah sure you want
to go buy that vegas one of my favorite
musicians name wolf though
my name is how's that baby [ __ ] up so
much in seven weeks they're like that
ain't it that ain't him he's no wolf
no why you say that the baby [ __ ] up
he didn't live up to the name he had
seven weeks
how dare you all he was doing was eating
and drinking and sleeping
here's a i gotta pitch some new names
for kylie and and uh
travis's new son's name
how about the
stampede
i knew that's where this was going
but yeah that's good
that's good what about
mass casualty event
[Laughter]
what about
nike
um nike yeah i i get it
in collaboration with the brand
yeah it'd be pa it would be a paid
collaboration obviously
stop laughing that's funny
[Laughter]
best sound bite over
uh okay
what else you got there yeah nick cage
did a photo shoot oh yeah we need your
opinion on this stila i need it we need
to fit check i mean it seems very nic
cage the vibe
fearless what is this
this guy [ __ ] dude why is the font so
lame
that's awesome
this one's kind of sick
yeah it's kind of a vibe but what's with
the cover the fearless font really don't
like it
okay
what is the why is his neck like that
i don't like the pose
try it it doesn't make any sense this
one is cool
this one i don't it doesn't make any
sense
why is he doing that with his neck it
looks like he's doing a joke
like he's trying to do neck football
it's like an elvis thing
he's a huge elvis fan
does that do anything for you
no
not especially
the [ __ ] dress
i don't love this photo [ __ ] no not
feeling it what about this one
[Laughter]
it's me nick cage at an enviro at an
abandoned mine
uh processing factory
well that they started strong yeah wait
go up jazz hands
well that's one kind of fire
yeah
he's slim takes care of himself ooh
the batman that's a good one
nah
nah that's cheesy that's his special
attack yeah his bb
his power attack i thought he's going
thanos
dirt dirt throw baby
he's dirt rider
his turret rider guys
yeah this is that right there this one
is bad right this is just
what i want to frame that dude oh my god
i love this
kind of funny who made the joke about
the excavator here
he's like
i forgot who made it but
somebody said he's looking to avenge
jeff right here
wow
oh it was cam
cam
it's like a venomous photoshoot
this is like remember what happened to
jeff's head
[Laughter]
oh man
there's some good pictures in here i
think they needed to narrow it down more
you know the first one is so cool
some of them are weak the ones with the
white suit
cut the whole
the one with the colorful background is
a mess
[Music]
there goes ryder
oh what's that ghost writer
he played ghost writer oh yeah
wait the quartering challenged me to a
debate when did this happen
oh i think it was that's been in the
dock for a couple weeks now the
quartering enemy of the show
look at all these thumbnails you made
about me i don't know if you've seen
this it's so funny
his thumbnail game is crazy dude yeah
thanks ethan there's more
a new low for ethan klein
like what is happening here my head's in
a claw machine yeah this is because we
made fun of his claw machine video he
got very
upset about that one ethan klein
epically fails to reveal my darkest
secret
and his fans turn on him i don't think
that happened
i don't really recall anybody yeah i
don't know
deep undercover by the way it seems like
my the ones with my name in it do well
for him
in general right yeah
that's nice
because i don't think they all get this
many views
like two to four hundred thousand yeah
look at that one with the with the
eyebrow gets a lot of views
oh yeah and he posts like five videos a
day it's
it's scary
when did this happen no but i think
these are good ones i think he gets a
lot of views when he
when he shows me hold on
the quartering oh yeah no you're
definitely right i mean
he he has the shotgun blast approach so
he just puts out like like look at his
who's watching it yeah so
kylie he had already four videos today
yeah
but you see it normally he's get pulling
like a hundred thousand and this one
even has less
right shit's coming so i'm i'm a i'm a
cow for him which is great i mean like
i'm gonna buy soon he's gonna name a new
shed after me
he's going to have his ethan climb shed
i'm [ __ ] my pants
past two hours
yeah look at this this one about me
seems like the most highly viewed
of this whole batch here i am still kind
of disturbed by how many people actually
watch him yeah i can't imagine actually
watching the quartering like how much is
your brain rotted out
nah bro i don't like jeremy either
but yeah this one quartering memes you
know that's going to be good
[Applause]
hey there i'm jeremy and you've come to
that part of youtube where you might be
wondering how the heck you got here
together with my people so wait is it
never seen this before this is before he
started drifting before his villain
origin story review or he was rejected
in the seventh grade and and went on a
rampage against all women yeah so the
quartering before he went on a
right-wing grifting rampage he was
trying to be like a carnival games gamer
we record our journeys as we travel
across the country i'm sorry but like
dude how do you have fans
well where is his part so far
i want to see what does he say about it
the top comment is who's this woman who
decided to spend a life with jeremy the
lack of self-awareness from ethan is
astounding i guess they're they have the
same question for you hila
hi my name is ela yeah who is who are
you decided to spend your life with me
only possible i wish you went down i'm
sorry dude i know i'm not like the most
[ __ ] but you gotta admit i have more
swag than jeremy
jeremy is like a human cumstain
i don't think it's a question
he he he's like he's jeremy is like the
human embodiment of a [ __ ] [ __ ] sock
that's been
stashed under someone's bed for a month
a little came out
so anyway uh ethan panics and deletes
tons of videos after joe rogan mess cost
him thousands of followers what the
[ __ ] he talking about we didn't erase
any videos i think you deleted the
jordan uh peterson episode oh
i believe that i didn't panic delete i i
i i erased this decision and you talked
about it related to joe rogan
i have no idea
i panics and deletes this guy's got good
clickbait
you gotta love that i literally deleted
it of my own volition
a smart move
uh ethan klein
picks a fight with jordan peterson
and gets roasted
history podcasts spiral into irrelevance
here i am with a bottle of coke
dude where the [ __ ] his thumbnail game
is insane yeah
you can't hate on it
i don't get some good thumbnails uh oh
and then they keep using this picture of
me in the diaper
from a sketch we did yeah
ethan clyde just made everything worse
after insulting joe rogan and goes full
meltdown on twitter
and now he's using pictures of me from
frenemies
you think lion insults my wife and makes
unhinged to our video about me
that was when we did the content court
literally did not insult you nobody
insulted your wife yeah
still not true
either client is collapsing
over joe rogan snub
what
losing thousands of subscribers he
declined destroyed by jordan peterson
after trying to cancel him
i love this the soapbox
and he looking all sad
steven crowder embarrasses ethan klein
busted lying
and cowardly bring sam cedar h3 podcast
fail nice
keyword stuffing yeah i watch a streamer
that wants to pee in the potty so these
guys are all friends like him and
crowder and all that
no that none of those people care about
jeremy
this is honestly a great thumbnail ethan
gone gets demolished after calling out
joe rogan and the internet drags him
batman bad
you can climb demolished by the
quartering and debate what debate when
did that happen
apparently we've debated oh
we don't have to do it already happened
joe rogan went nuclear and ethan klein
retreats into hiding after backlash
i have no idea man i really don't know
i'm crushed by tim poole
jordan peter laughs at me
oh this these are amazing
tricia drama either the client implodes
as trisha paytas leaks testament text
message huge trouble for h3
wow so it's not just political drama
it's just any drama yeah
dude this is a lot yeah this is a lot i
haven't talked about him this much
this much maybe not that much
i mean
but it's hard to tell because he makes
dedicated like 10 minute videos and so
like they're dedicated to this i mean we
made
a content chord about him and then he's
been a frequent
subject of ridicule on the show so
i think it's probably on balance about
this
this one is a twist and and and i'm not
sure what to make of it rice gum attacks
goddess ela cline from h3
yup not ironic
how the [ __ ] about that i don't know i
think that's what it really boils down
to is he he's a
he's an example of one of these scorned
fans i think he he really liked you back
in the day he said as much i don't think
that's even a secret yeah still has
those videos up
and uh
you know
then all of a sudden this person that he
looks up to is uh ragging on him all the
time
well he's a well yeah he's a rag right
yeah
um
dude this is look at this ether glide
demands
he's got me at the dead sea
and me with charcoal beauty products
and these go way back [ __ ]
yeah that's a lot but the thumbnails are
wild so shout out to his uh whoever does
that yeah
shout out that's for a raise
and if it's jeremy then kudos if you're
the one making those because those are
good
what did jeremy say he says i've got
them all wrong
um
you know i'd like to extend
an invitation to speak
to ethan
i genuinely don't think he has any clue
who i am or what my actual opinions are
i think he goes off of
maybe what other people say about me on
twitter or something because something i
mean i watch your videos dumbass
that's how i draw my conclusions about
what you say in your videos on your
channel criticisms he has for me are
just so incorrect and so opposite of
what i actually believe
that i think he's built me up as some
sort of weird villain in his mind i will
never like you bro
you're vile
you have vile opinions
you say vile things and actually you do
vile things like [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] basement
and waffle stomping with your bare feet
quick correction he [ __ ] in walmart [ __ ]
in walmart pissed in his basement
let's stick to the facts here
he pees in his basement and rumor has it
he also shits in his basement and waffle
stomps it with his bare feet down the
drain
got it
so i mean
all right we're way over two hours
let's wrap it up we gotta go to vegas
because i criticized them you know
uh anything else
nah
kanye band don't care just want me to
cut you all down your hair you're being
cut off call me carson don't care
jordan peterson update
now this is interesting it's not an
update it's like four weeks old at this
point it's just been at the bottom of
the dock for a while
so jimmy lee we're postponing to next
week
by the way right
thanks for watching everybody guys
thanks for watching we're going to be in
vegas this weekend
bearing up the [ __ ] tables
putting a thousand on can you put up a
poll i need the people's vote oh boy i'm
gonna put a thousand when we first
arrive
and i need to know do the people say
black
i'm not gonna do green green is [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah guys tell me if i should vote black
or red and then zach you want to wrap it
up sure i'm putting up the poll right
now
um also
there was a 100 donation
i wanted to read out uh
this money is for a b i want everyone
else in the studio to match it and have
him bedded on black this weekend happy
birthday buddy i'll match that hundred
no you want thank you so much
why do people donate it's just pain in
the ass to donate and then say i gotta
give it to abe
all right what did they give you a
hundred bucks so i gotta give you 100
bucks now
well he asked you don't have to
he said this hundreds for a b no they
want everybody to match it and then him
gamble it right everybody's got to give
you a hundred bucks
well not ever you don't have to i'm
volunteering paying for the whole trip
i'll give you a little pass no i'm the
guy just gave 100 bucks for you i got to
give it to you now
appreciate it you just gave him like
three grand today
that's three random farts that's true
man uh by the way black has it by by a
long time okay good so we're both on
black okay i'm gonna give you a hundred
bucks
and then i'm gonna give you a hundred
bucks from him and then from us right
and then everyone put 100 on it right or
who wants to donate right
i'm going to put a thousand on black
right
if i win i'm going to turn up i'm going
to pass i'm going to give everyone money
let's [ __ ] go shout out to that
commentator so we need black guys please
everybody will black we need black black
black black black black
black black black black have you visited
black
black
all right we're feeling black what
percentage did black win by uh 66 to 34.
blocked yeah that's so odd
that in a 50 50 people would pre
preference blackboard blocked
whoa yellow
all right guys blocked it is blocked it
is
we'll let you know how it goes on monday
yep this is going to be the big roll
this is it oh we're going to lose it oh
i've been bringing the losers
all right take us out ian thank you go
ahead uh no zach
oh
right right now thank you guys so much
for tuning in we appreciate all the love
the support make sure to smash that
subscribe
button smash that like button turn on
your notifications because we got the
best family in the game we got the best
family in the game
and give it up to the cousins
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
[Music]
you're watching h to the three three
three
you're watching